ما مدى وضوح الدليل على جرائم الحرب ،
وكيف تتجمع هذه الصورة معًا ،
أفترض أنها تتجمع لأننا
رأينا ، أعني أنني رأيت الكثير من
الأدلة التي تغطيها في هذا العرض
جيدًا. جيم هناك أدلة هائلة على
جرائم الحرب ونحن  لقد رأينا أدلة في
بوتشا في المناطق المعادية والمناطق المحيطة
بأم أه كييف لكننا لم نر وما
رأيناه حتى الآن هو مجرد غيض من
فيض هو تلك المناطق الواقعة تحت
الاحتلال الروسي ، لذا فمن
المحتمل أن تكون ماريوبال أمرًا  حجم أسوأ
مما رأيناه حتى الآن
مدينة بأكملها يبلغ عدد سكانها بضع مئات
الآلاف من السكان والتي تم
تسويتها عمليًا ولن نتعرف على
شكل جرائم الحرب في تلك المنطقة
حتى نتمكن من الوصول إليها  وما
نبحث عنه هناك
هجوم عشوائي على أهداف مدنية أه مدنيين
إنه انتهاك لمبدأ رئيسي أو حاسم
للحرب يسمى أه تمييز
حيث لا يمكنك مهاجمة المدنيين والأعيان
المدنية ومجموعتنا
تساعد الحكومة الأوكرانية في
التحقيق في ذلك
وأنت  لقد قلنا أن القادة الروس
لن يهربوا أبدًا من المساءلة عن
جرائمهم بغض النظر عن المدة التي تستغرقها
أنت تقصد بوتين عندما تقول كذلك
لا أنت
أعني بوتين أعني أه
مساعديه المباشرين وأعني ضباط
الجيش الذين هم  يحاربون هذا
الصراع إذا فكرنا في تحقيقات أه جرائم الحرب ، فهم
طويلون
يجتهدون في أن الأوكرانيين
لديهم حاليًا ما يقرب من 74000 قضية مفتوحة
واه ليس لديهم ما يقرب من
74000 مدع عام ، لذلك سيتطلب الأمر
قدرًا كبيرًا  من الوقت والجهد والمساعدة
من قبل
المنظمات الدولية مثل بلدي وغيرها التي
ستدخل وتساعد الأوكرانيين أه
في هذه أه المهمة الشاقة الهائلة وهي
عملية ستستغرق
وقتًا طويلاً إذا فكرت في أه
الحرب العالمية الثانية أه  الألمان مازالوا
يرفعون قضايا أه من الحرب العالمية الثانية
العام الماضي أه يوغوسلافيا التي مضى عليها عدة
عقود الآن هناك قضايا جارية ولذا
فهي قضية أه مسألة
توثيق ومن ثم الاستعداد
لمحاكمة هذه القضايا عندما
تسنح الفرصة نفسها